we're very fortunate that present car
you're going to join us on the panel
which means that when the questions and
answers when you want to ask us any
questions please feel free to ask him
questions as well and I'm addressing
here the students over here the other
thing I wanted to say if you notice this
pan in the last two panels we had the
moderator first sitting on one end and
the second panel in the other end over
here I decided I'm going to sit in the
middle because what we want to have is
not presentations by the panelists but
actually a discussion and I would like
you to be joining in the discussion and
I would like the students in particular
since this panel is about you it is
about education and if you feel
comfortable enough to move in front
there are so many chairs here in front
please do move over to the front so that
you can join if you feel like it at home
if you're too shy you can stay where you
are I thought that what i would do here
I actually have a very interesting panel
that I have apart from the president I
have two people from academia from this
universities and two people who are
actors in the private sector so we're
going to have a wonderful interaction
between the two but and and what I would
like to do is to introduce them very
quickly here on my immediate left I have
pradeep khosla he's the Dean of the
College of Engineering and the Philip
the marshal dial university professor at
the Carnegie Mellon on my left yes more
left I have there's a Shannon skyla
she's the managing director of corporate
responsibility for
PricewaterhouseCoopers on my immediate
right is Thomas piller and despite his
name he's French and he's the senior
director of international programs and
he told me not to say FAS its ass
and further to my right is Professor
Susan Polanski who teaches Hispanic
studies and it is the head of the
Department of Modern Languages here at
Carnegie Mellon before I turned to the
discussions over here I thought I will
draw your attention and create the
context for some of the discussion
that's going to take place now by
summarizing the three papers by three or
three contributors who are not here on
the podium with us today all of them
very interesting and the other
contributors are here so they can speak
for themselves but there's a three very
good papers rustle Berman argues for
restarting the engine of globalization
something that we have been talking
about today all morning particularly as
it had run out of steam with the recent
global economic meltdown he does
acknowledge the anxieties that
globalization triggers because of the
labor mobility which brings different
cultures and languages into contact and
he concludes with several
recommendations in order to prepare the
future international workforce and these
recommendations range from learning a
second language and I think we're going
to be hearing about that more about that
from Susan here and cultural immersion
courses which are very important to
promoting Universalists and liberal
democratic principles he goes on to
stress the importance of teaching the
humanities and the liberal arts and I
think we hear about that more about that
later on as well and by doing that he's
warning against a narrow focus on
technological training I suppose the
second paper I were read was by Robert
dagger and he bases his argument on
research that demonstrates the benefit
early childhood education yields in the
form of increased labor productivity
competitiveness economic growth and job
creation and he recommends that
governments invest more in high quality
early childhood programs and I feel that
even the developed countries have not
really invested enough in early
childhood programs the paper by Arthur
rothco Rothkopf laments the failure of
the US educational system to prepare
students for the 21st century through
quality education and in particular for
failing to orient them and equip them
for the growth occupations in the
sciences technology engineering and
mathematics stem some okay he contrasts
the anticipated twenty eight point eight
percent growth of employment in
professional and scientific and
technical services by 2016 which will
actually add 2.1 million jobs with the
contraction of the degrees in these
fields that are conferred by us
institutions and he goes on to say
specifically that American citizens
students are actually only just above
fifty percent of those who actually get
these degrees and he contrasts that with
the contraction in conferring both
master and bachelor degrees he does see
signs of improvement with policies
encouraging education reforms but he
argues that more needs to be done and to
address these the challenges of this new
millennium Dean khosla argues that the
world needs more scientists and
engineers not only in the United States
but in other countries because no single
country can actually produce the numbers
that are needed and he said the success
of the American research university but
admits that it's not going to be easy
easily replicated in other countries and
this raises a number of questions that I
would like to
I ask of the discussants over here and
one of the first one that comes to my
mind it seems to me that most of these
papers were actually focusing on the
United States and Europe and and I think
Dean koestler comes up with a very
important issue that this is not going
what is happening in the United States
is not going to be possible everywhere
it may be possible in some places but it
cannot be replicated everywhere and the
question is how how is that going to
actually increase the gap between the
developed countries and the developing
countries and what can and particularly
as we're talking about the g20 that is
looking not only at the developed
country but at the whole world what can
be done over here and what and what are
the recommendations or at least what are
the questions that we need to be asking
to be able to counter some of these gaps
that are going to take place the other
thing that I that comes to my mind again
is in looking at this focus and these
jobs that are going to be created
whether in they've developed or
developing countries in terms of
mathematics sciences and etc it's an
area where women are not necessarily
encouraged to to invest in and what does
that mean in terms of the gender gap in
terms of job finding does that mean that
you know most of these jobs which are
going to be probably in the private
sector although obviously in the public
sector as well does that mean that we're
going to end up seeing a feminization of
the of the public sector for example and
I throw these questions first starting
with the person who actually brings up
this whole issue where this cannot be
replicated everyone thank you sighs so
before I start I should tell you that
I'm not an economist but what I've
learned in my
life or short life out here is that an
economist and a non economist has nearly
equal probability of being right on any
issue that has to do with account but
somehow this is not working so so what
you read out there op-ed piece and based
on the following operation again picking
up from newspapers if you look at the
role of economic development I don't
think it is only to make rich people
richer it's also in the underdeveloped
countries to bring people out of poverty
so now if you take just an example China
just for China to maintain status quo
we're about seven hundred plus million
people are still you know below nearly
poverty level they have to maintain
growth rates of eight to ten a status
goes about six percent a reasonable
number of people to come out of poverty
is between eight and ten percent these
are not reasonable growth rates in a
global economic sense and up to now
post-world war two my conjecture right
or wrong somebody can correct me is the
US has been the main driver of
innovation creation of ideas creation of
wealth and it has spread it around the
whole world pretty much other countries
are followed up but not enough and now
these other countries like China India I
think the African region have to pick up
and invest in their education
infrastructure and replicate a model
which I don't think is the only model
but that's the only model I know which
has demonstrated success which is the
American research university model and
has been extremely successful so that
was my basis so I don't think it's
impossible to replicate that model and
this would be a question with Jerry as
he's been thinking about
internationalization and investing a lot
in our international activities maybe he
can throw some light on how he thinks
that we have actually changed the
culture in some of these places but we
are talking about our program in Africa
right now starting from scratch to
create economic development using mainly
ICT technologies right and this is the
part of a country and in a region where
STEM education is much less valued than
in the US or in India or China where I
think women's rights are a bigger
problem than one would think about but I
think these are the types of places we
have to be going into to really make a
powerful impact our a higher return on
investment on our investment or for time
to change the world around us stuff and
much to add to what pretty just said
other than my own observation that this
is an interesting question as to how
many research universities the world can
afford or how many does it need in fact
there's a study being undertaken by the
National Academy of Sciences to try to
answer that question from the US
perspective again but it'll be
generalizable one of the moments in time
I recall which is instructive was a time
when I'm not sure does why it happened
then I think it was probably them during
the 70's it seemed that every every
public university in every state felt
that it should be a full-fledged
research university and actually the
state of Wisconsin set out to do that
and they already had like a dozen state
colleges and they realized very quickly
they go broke before they could ever
pursue that now it's not from a u.s.
perspective is that hard to understand
why every college wants to be a
university in every one university wants
to be Harvard or probably Carnegie
Mellon I and so there's that drive for
stature and statures tend to be defined
as a research university and that's
crazy we can't afford that that requires
tough decisions it's particularly
interesting i think from a developing
country point of view where there's huge
educational needs and they would simply
cannot be or won't be delivered by a
single research university so some mix
of
educational institutions is called for I
don't think we have any sense of what
that makes ought to be or even how to go
about answering the question well I just
want to add a point to that discussion
which is indeed and thanks for your word
about the ecology because that that's my
background and that's where that's what
I do now is that if you look at Africa
for instance where the large populations
group the population who do not have
access to basic education at all because
lack of infrastructure lack of resources
lack of money we and a number of other
companies are working on project like
you know it's not even e-education it's
M education in Africa and many countries
out there is no broadband no computer no
electricity sometimes lots of people
have mobile phones very simple devices
very cheap one dollar per month limited
connection think about the power that it
would have on local communities to
develop educational content that can be
delivered through mobile phone then you
already start reaching out hundreds of
millions of kids who do not have access
to education today same for central
India when i'ma no problems here so
think about IT not only in terms of
laptops computer you know broadband
network this is one part of the equation
think about the telecommunication part
of it and also think that I t there is
not only the device it's the content
it's it's a content which is accessible
which also needs to be multilingual you
mentioned your effort in Qatar and that
and that's great because actually if you
look at the middle east with not
mistaken fifty to sixty percent of the
population is below 20 or I can years
old huge education needs and remember to
your point technology is is gender
neutral when you sit being a computer
nobody cares if you're a woman none but
you can see that so you can still
deliver education to people or to teach
today wouldn't have access to it so I
think that we should really look at
technology as a way to reach out to
unserved
and uneducated to the population and no
need to invest billions of dollars in
infrastructure mobile phones that as
simple as that and she look at the
beginner at Kenya that's where they're
going to now and 11 comment about what
you said you said that number of your
students if i'm not mistaken i'm not
very interested into global issues right
for those for those who are in the room
that's a huge mistake because maybe that
you don't care that much about the world
but the u.s. cares very much still about
the USA so a lot of countries to look at
the US as a model for innovation
technology new IDs so you should really
get engaged into that global programs
because that's where your future is and
because people still again look at the
US as a possible place the ones who are
here are interested so buddy of mines my
concern is the ones who are you tell
your friends to be engaged i should pick
up on two points that thomas mentioned
and i'm here kind of as a voice of
humanities but i can't help pick up on
the technology for a moment and that is
just yesterday in our graduate research
seminar one of our graduate students is
doing work on by literacy in bangalore
and she's working with a slum children
there and they are so right for dealing
with technology they try to get to the
internet cafe they do have tb's when
they don't have roofs over their heads
and yet they they are really ready to
absorb this in that way and then
speaking about your comment about the
half of the students perhaps here at the
campus that don't seem to show interest
the half that do at least judging from
the close to fifty percent that are
taking Modern Languages and certainly
studying the humanities these students
are getting amazing education to prepare
for global citizenship and those that
kind of question the value of the
humanities in this day in terms of its
applicability we see that the
interdisciplinary nature of the
education here really goes a long way I
think the other
that's really fascinated about the
education topic and when we at pwc talk
about corporate responsibility it's a
combination of everything from community
outreach to sustainability to our ethics
programs to diversity kind of the whole
gamut of things and when we look across
those 150 territories around the globe
and are 150,000 people and try to figure
out what are some common denominators
that we can talk about there's one so
far that we've come up with and that's
education because there's not one leader
in any of our network of firms that are
out there that don't see where they are
anywhere in the globe education being a
key issue to the success of their local
marketplace as well as the success of
the global marketplace and I think it's
important to look at education very
holistically and so it's one thing to go
in and to talk specifically about the
training the courses technology the
different ways to do it but I think we
also have to realize that there are some
things that are standing in the way of
education everything from children not
being appropriately nourished to safety
issues just getting children to school
and I and I think part of the things
that we really wrestle with and we're
seeing it in the US and and it's
something we have to help people manage
across the globe is a lot of time is
spent now when you think of your days in
K through 12 a lot of time now is spent
with children is not learning in the US
schools now are taught to be the places
where you go and we feed you and it's a
safe place to spend that eight hours a
day and you take extracurricular
activities and those are all great but
there's not as much learning and we've
said compared to other China and India
and other places we do some things
really well but we're not spending the
time teaching especially in K through 12
as is happening in other places and so
that's really become something that we
can talk about globally around PwC
what's happening in the US as the US
certainly takes the lead on some things
but what can we learn and then how can
we use
the size and in our leverage to then
talk to school districts around the
country to figure out how we can do it
different here but I think there's a lot
of other barriers to education and you
really have to start at that most
fundamental young level because that's
what's going to set the stage for the
future and that's really what's going to
be what we need to change so years from
now we're not looking back and saying
gosh we have the senior vice president
position and we need a woman to fill it
that's going to be because you hired
somebody fifteen years ago and they're
suddenly in the place to do it if you
need the person it's too late you're not
going to get it so really starting with
how can we get more people who were
interested in the county fields how can
we get more people who were interested
in humanities that can join our
innovation department starting way back
then is really going to help us in the
future I think one of the challenges
that I I can never forget is that if you
look at the human the undp human
development report the most recent one
you find that 18 countries have a
literacy rate that is below fifty
percent way below and many many others
who are hovering in the fifty percent
and when you start talking about you
know mathematics and and and Sciences
and moving forward how does one
reconcile what is going on in some parts
of the world where yes I'm glad you
talked about the mobile phone because
you know when we talk about computers to
countries where the electricity is about
two or three hours a day and I would
like to find out how can i pee perhaps
help in reaching out to to the younger
population and whether that is possible
and how is it possible particularly with
the language problems well I definitely
think it's possible when you look at
many kids today maybe not in the poorest
countries in the world but they have all
you know
iphones or ipods or xbox and they are
online or they are playing online we
chatting with friends all the time and
I'm going to maybe to use a clich but
then they go to the classroom and it
becoming too kind of ossified may be
boring environment when there is a
person on a platform to tell them what
to learn so there is a disconnect here
between the way the content is delivered
and their daily lives well it's very
interactive very immediate you know they
get friends all over the world no it's
different so I think that one of the
challenges is to integrate the content
the education content in a format that
actually speaks to kid and then it can
use it and they can benefit from it and
that's the first challenge but i think
that the benefit from IT and ICT to see
I mean information and telecommunication
technologies is that we can personalize
it I mean the Internet is all about you
your own taste the way you leave the way
you spend where you behave IT can
actually help personalizing invocation
to the needs of a particular student or
particular group of students versus
having one one size fits all approach
and i think that's that's crucial not
only for the developing world well come
from in europe that's also one of the
issues and parents do complain about the
fact that their kid you know get the
cementation as the other kid even if
their needs are different they are need
as in as a young individual so I think
here there is a lot of investment to be
made by the IT community because let's
be clear that's a huge market that's
huge market and and that's one thing
language content the local language
content is is a key question again if
you look at the Middle East less than
four percent of the entire internet
pages is in Arabic so that's a huge
challenge that we need to address and
the fact that now many companies like
Google are a buying firms in the Middle
East software companies to develop
content in Arabic is a very good sign
meaning that we are going to reach out
to the population which is underserved
today
and because of you know social
considerations maybe parents don't trust
that kids to go to the internet to learn
stuff in English I'd rather have them
learn stuff in Arabic on the internet so
yes there is an content issuer thinking
starting to be addressed because again
and I'll be very clear this is this is
money opportunity for companies so we
will do it because there is a market
it's like two problems here right one is
Jerry talked about Ed's and meds and it
was a very positive spin on it and we
put a slightly negative spin on Ed's and
meds if you look at health care and
education in about 20 more years they
will be more than half our GDP which
doesn't make sense right so the cost of
these things is going up really fast
secondly people in poor countries cannot
afford high quality education and i
think it is in this context it occurs to
me that the program that Jerry laid out
and maybe we should know more about this
the only program which allows for
customized education at reasonably
inexpensive delivery mechanism would be
a value do you think Jerry this could be
yes we're betting on that and it's why
we've invested so much effort in this
there's a really interesting question I
I think this is relevant to this
discussion and even if it isn't that I
hope you'll all think about this it's
what an entrepreneur would call the
business model or a business leader
would call the business model how do you
get from the dozen courses we've
developed suppose you agree these
courses are terrific in the world ought
to happen how do you go from the Dozen
courses to the say thousand that we need
when you consider that each of those
courses is cost like a million dollars
to put the other and let's suppose we
can get the cost down to one hundred
thousand dollars still a huge amount of
money and so how do you get from the
pilot stage to a scaled-up stage and you
know every one of us in this audience
I'm sure feels that the world deserves
as a right to this education it ought to
be freely available certainly there are
foundation
a private foundation people feel
strongly that way we don't disagree
those of us involved in the program but
we asked the question where's the money
going to come from the foundation
communities that could have put up one
hundred million dollars to create a
thousand courses that's what the private
sector is formed you can say so if
there's a way to commercialize this
maybe companies like SAS or are the ones
to do it so that you can raise the
capital you need to create the content
in the first place that's it seems us to
keep but we haven't figured that out you
don't know what the business model is
and you can't ignore it and I think that
that's really critical we're working
with several universities because one of
the things that really links together
the humanities and the technology is not
just having it of course that's
encounted and when we bring a lot about
5,000 new accounting majors a year in
the US but they need to have a lot more
than just an accounting background and
so how does ethics fit into that
equation how does sustainability fit
into that equation how does
globalization fit into that equation not
just accounting courses and so we've
come in and helped universities to
develop courses around corporate
responsibility in a more holistic sense
because that's the kind of thinking that
we now need as most of our people come
in and they're working on multinational
clients and so that's a way to build
these partnerships which is critical
because there's not one group that's
going to solve these issues and so we
have to find ways that we can work
together with nonprofits and companies
and governments to really make a dent in
this because it's too costly and nobody
really have the resources to do it on
their own you mentioned cost as a great
challenge and you also mentioned the
word content and that I think is really
also a very big challenge to train
people who as my colleague Steve
Brockman said this morning are sensitive
to the particularity zuv culture that
culture matters and so to develop
products that are going to be successful
and to have people well-trained both
language and culture wise and
in terms of the humanities have the
analytical and communication skills to
go with it is extremely important I'm
sorry White House it just say it's a
fair question is whether that's
achievable a lot of long totally Ottawa
I was going to say I'm being an optimist
I think it's achievable right for the
president away they're like yeah it's a
mad job Susan back your point I think
Carnegie Mellon and some of the places
but here for sure we are looking at
changing engineering education with a
more holistic and bring innovation
entrepreneurship technology change
Modern Languages all into the curriculum
including yeah this is broken yeah not
because I'm holding the wire instead of
chewing gum it's my finger holding okay
so I was going to say in at Carnegie
Mellon we are thinking and working very
actively are changing the curriculum to
include Modern Languages global politics
and all of these current relevant
topical areas and issues into a holistic
education of this next generation of
engineer that on one hand I argued India
and China should graduate more and now
I'm arguing that let them graduate more
and we'll go manage their more graduates
because that's where that way we'll have
more value creation at our end right so
we are trying to change our curriculum
to while we are arguing that
international community has to be
serious about educating more people so
no question we go back to that eight
point six percent of university students
that study languages and cultures in
addition to English we know that English
is the lingua franca at the same time
multilingual corporations are looking
for people proficient in languages and
cultures and in the humanities to have a
broader background and would like to
hire more people of that sort and it's
not the market is not
if I me I just like wood to go back to
your starting point of developing
countries that we tend to be so us and
Eurocentric in our thinking for obvious
reasons I guess we've had quite a bit
experience now in other countries and of
course one cannot and should not lump
them all together so there are countries
like India which we know well which
generates a lot of university level
graduates not nearly enough to support
their own economy and what we hear from
their employers the Indian employers of
those students is exactly what you're
talking about says that is we've figured
out how to do technical training but now
that we need people who are customer
facing as they put it we need people who
has who have language skills and
communication skills and management
skills they need a broader sense of the
world beyond India and they realize that
their university simply don't do that
now and there's a big gap there in
addition they have just an enormous gap
between the demand for higher education
as you know in the supply of it so
that's India and that's challenging
enough but then you all as some of you
know Africa certainly you know Africa
much better than I but as Thomas may
reference to before we're talking about
places that don't have to have access
basically to nothing so that the the
state of the educational system in some
of those countries is so far away from
the notion of an American research
university that as so as to make what we
do simply not relevant and each of these
classes I think or groups types of
situation requires its own thought on
program to make progress
one student comes to mind is that one
issue that comes to my mind is actually
be educated in those developing
countries who end up actually leaving
and the brain drain that is caused by
that so that's one issue please I just
want to make two points the first about
what interested about India we see as a
company we see the same issue in
Singapore and South Korea despite a very
high level of development it's very
modern places the ministry of education
comes to us I can you help us introduce
that those of humanity named and the
program now about the business model
that that's a very good question I
personally see the start of a new
coalition if you if you want between the
education world between the IT world and
between the telecommunication world
those three starts starts to converge
and to realize that yes there is
possibility to collaborate and to create
a new business model because so far I
agree it's not very clear who can who is
going to pay what when and for what type
of content but I see I see I see for
instance know a big multinational Lee
communication companies like suffer
economy and in Africa who serve many
many countries in Africa starting to ask
IT companies can you develop you know
though that in content for us so we can
deliver on the on mobile phone so and
the demon is coming from from the
telecommunication side because they see
an advantage here to deliver new
services so I'm not saying that it's
done and everything is perfect but I
believe that there is a very possible
way to collaborate even more there and
very interestingly from my perspective
this is coming from Middle East and
Africa mostly right now questions
exactly can
we've been talking in some ways about
essentially decentralizing education in
a lot of ways and currently schools hold
a monopoly on education but at the same
time as you were yeah but at the same
time president cone you were talking
about how much countries look to the
American model and for standards because
they know that we have high standards
and we know they know that we can
deliver that so in a decentralized model
what you're delivering education through
different means possibly financed in
interesting ways with private companies
in these kinds of things how do you keep
a level of standards that people know
they're going to be able to get a job
when they've got that education or as
opposed to a sort of infosys model where
you're essentially training somebody to
make up for a shortfall that that you're
then just employ them and use them in
that way it's a great question actually
some of us had a chance to meet
privately with Bill Gates yesterday
Randy Bryant Athena computer science the
Provos and I and this was exactly what
we talked a great deal about he made the
point and it's a very good one that
they're basically one way to think about
what higher education does or has to do
is three things develop the content
deliver the content and then deliver the
credential and his observation was
because of Technology those three
functions are starting to separate or
maybe separable in a way they never were
before that is to get the Carnegie
Mellon credential of a degree you had to
come and live on our campus as the way
we delivered that our Carnegie Mellon
content to you and technology raises the
question of what's going to happen when
those things get separated and we don't
have great answers that especially the
credentialing part of it the one the
issues you just raised I'll just point
out again another commercial but I got
the mic and I'm the president one of the
great breakthroughs in this
open learning technology that we've
corporated is it's very heavy on
interaction between the student and the
module computer and built into that is
real-time assessment of how the student
is doing so you can imagine and indeed
what we anticipate is there is someone
sitting in Pittsburgh monitoring the
progress of students in Africa the
Middle East or wherever they're taking
the course and so that we know how the
students doing we also know how to
adjust the content by the way over time
I me not in real time so there is a way
to do credentialing from a distance but
it requires I think institutions that
will do the credentialing to think about
this in a very different way from the
way they used to think about it and we
speaking for this university we're not
there yet but we're clearly thing about
it I it's a great question a Jerry just
in reaction to your conversation
yesterday I think he said was with Bill
Gates I think he might left some things
off that are important to an institution
like ours that we've been talking about
education as content delivery but I
think there's more to our education than
just raw content or technical content
and part of that is socialization what
is an educated person but it's also how
do you develop thinking models and how
do you become a better thinker and I'm
and if we strip those out then I'm not
sure we're actually providing the
service and the education that we should
be doing it's a great point Robert I'm
glad you mentioned it were to me the
countervailing forces of separating the
three I talked about are two one is that
that is that being residential and by
that I using that a shorthand as having
a community of students who are study
together over time is very hard to
replace by through technology at a
distance in terms of its value exactly
the way you said global as they have
socialization
broadening a perspective the other is
clap of research and of course at the
research university like ours the
connection of that to the educational
experience that's also hard to do at a
distance I'm hesitant to say we'll never
be able to figure how to do that I'm
kind of hoping we don't because that
will really undermine the model of a
Carnegie Mellon maybe but i'm headed to
say you can never do that because we're
surrounded by some of the great
technology minds in the world and who
knows what they'll come up with but
that's a great point i agree with you
completely hi this is a question for
president Cohen I apologize
distinguished panel with regard to the
open learning program that you're
developing excuse me your name Steven
Taylor I'm a master's student in the
public policy program with regard to
funding you mentioned that a private
partnership is what you are looking at
and someone who's actually worked in a
school that has there was private and
for-profit I saw how there were the
conflicting goals of making money and
educating students really affected the
education do you believe that it's
impossible or improbable that the
scale-up that you were talking about can
be funded through the traditional
governmental nonprofit channels like
through for instance through community
colleges they are subsidized by the
government students pay tuition is it
possible that there can be maybe a
slower ramp up but without the profit
motive to increase the number of courses
that you can offer I I hope so and maybe
indeed this next phase were embarking on
with community colleges will help us
understand a lot to reserve try and
answer that question and I respect your
point completely about the potential
conflict among multiple motives of
making money and
delivering high-quality learning a great
point and we'll see our goal is the
scale up as opposed to the profit
maximization whether you need the ladder
to get to the former remains to be seen
would be happy if we could do it
otherwise may may I had something to do
that I mean from the private sector
perspective I think this is something
where corporations must look at it from
a long-term perspective if it's if it's
info a quick bug that's not going to
work this is an investment because by
doing that we are going to create a
workforce of two more that we will need
in the US and everywhere around the
world so it's also a way to ensure
long-term sustainability and survival of
corporations but if it's only to make me
no money right now now i agree with you
that's not going to fly i have a
question on a very different topic
concerning education we are carnegie
mellon work with is inner city schools
some children in those schools when they
go to kindergarten they're not ready to
read they do not learn how to read if
they don't learn math or science they do
not get educated enough to join the
global economy this is Pittsburgh how
about Somalia Darfur the slums of india
a child who does not get educated does
not join the global economy which is not
good for the world or for them my
question is really to the g20 do we have
an obligation such that every child gets
educated that's the question does the
g20 feel that obligation a much much
much more difficult question is how do
we do it that's really difficult take a
who is three years old in a slummin for
India that child cannot wait until he or
she is 30 years old to get educated whea
corny game Ellen
have computer science we heard software
being discussed technology perhaps we
should invest not just money because any
dollar spent on education gets
multiplied every parent who plays that
pays the tuition at Carnegie Mellon
knows that it is technology isn't it
time for us to get to work to make sure
that every child gets educated thank you
and it's interesting that I do think
that there's a commitment around the
globe to do that and I think you're
right the problem is is people don't
know how to do it and I think that's
where it's the responsibility of all of
us to help in that you know we're
helping roll out a new form of math in
the u.s. st math spatial temporal
reasoning is that are especially no but
we're being asked to help schools we're
in the process of building for schools
and Chad and just adopted schools and
believes because they can't do it and
their governments have come and said can
you help us do it it's not necessarily
our responsibility but it is our
responsibility because that's going to
be the future workplace in the future
marketplace and so I think we're all
struggling to figure out what do we need
to do and how can we be a part of it and
as more people realize that what you're
saying is fundamental to our future and
we can't overlook it I think the more
people will be drawn together to work
together to figure out how do we make
that change I do see people committed to
it again it's the one thing that brings
all of our leaders to the table with
pounding fists but it's the hell and
what's our play in that what do we need
to do
hi my name is Caroline Kaufman I'm
something about fossil from Carnegie
Mellon because I graduated from here and
I started when it was still called
carnegie institute of technology and i
was told right up front by the Dean of
women that the reason this school was
started that Andrew Carnegie needed an
educated labor force two men his
factories and that was the raison D etre
and then after World War two there was a
specific effort to train returning War
veterans in basics algebra trigonometry
the the basic education of an end up
that you would need that would produce
the next generation of Engineers and I
think when we go searching for a
business model for how to advance
education maybe that's all we ought to
go but we ought to go back to that
sentiment you know of that's the reason
this whole institution started it did
start out to be you know a research
institution it started out to educate
the basic labor force so there would be
people around who could do the work that
Andrew Carnegie and his cohort of gilded
age industrialists needed to have done
so I think that maybe we could just
unpack it and go back to our roots if
you will and see it education in that
perspective and the other thought I had
is that you can teach typing and basic
literacy if a kid is just forced a text
message you know maybe it won't be the
best spelling in the world but you know
you got to start somewhere anyway I was
wondering what the panel's reaction were
was to that kind of thinking can I start
about a second point I mean if it's the
mean it is the way kids use you know
language today well we and because of
technology or in
many we should adapt to that situation
when I see some of my family they're
young kids how they use French I'm
horrified but that's their language and
that's going to post problem when they
are going to do for jobs that's that's
also an issue but well maybe we can can
at least add up some some of the content
to the situation just make sure that
they they still get plug in into the
different system otherwise we risk
losing them I'm not saying it's good
saying that's there so maybe it's up to
us to adapt some of our habits as well
okay we have five minutes and three
people who want to please make sure that
your questions are short and quick thank
you my name is Adam Jones like Steve and
I mob master's in public policy student
at the height in school and my question
surrounds the fact we talked a lot about
bringing technology to these places my
question for all of you on the panel is
how do we keep the human element whether
it be teachers or counselors or whatever
involved in education across the world
as our technology use increases why
don't we take the other two questions
and then ask the panel to wrap up this
gentleman here okay hi my name is Derek
hey sir I'm a student from statements
and colleges attending my question is
kind of running back to the what were
discussing the non-traditional forms of
education such as through the open
courses that were mentioned or through
communication via mobile phones and my
question to a kind of relates back to
the concepts of assessment on
authentication is that for example by
test with text messages there by nature
asynchronous and so you don't you lose
kind of the assessment feature that you
get with the open courseware it can
actually analyze how students are
performing and my other question is is
whenever you're doing this and you're
handing out credentials with it how do
you authenticate the person on the other
end of the connection to know that the
person who you're putting their name on
the certificate is actually the person
who's performing the work we take the
final question from there and then we
come back to the pow that's
hi my name is Jose argueta I'm from
Honduras I grew up there and and they
also grew very concerned with you know
poverty and all the problems that we
have over there so i came to the united
states to study you know how to make
better policies and decisions and
actually that's why i went to Yale
University and president Cohen was my
professor in in the class of decision
making an excellent class by the way and
so I learned a lot about you know how to
make better positions and and I also you
know continue my study is a PhD
political science tool and and and
because I was very concerned about you
know the political situation in the
country and they can say that we have
made you know a lot of progress in terms
of political reforms in the country but
there are still some problems that are
you know structural that our / ears for
my country's economic development and
and so we need to differentiate between
developing countries and developing
countries so so you can have developing
countries like China or India or Brazil
who have mail or progress and in
industrialization and economic
development but there are also countries
like mine honduras nicaragua south south
here and countries african countries we
don't have the leverage to all the
attractiveness to get foreign investment
or to get into the the global economy so
my question is you know how the new war
economy and the process of globalization
will help you know this you know little
countries that you know like
industrialization and are mostly you
know gradient societies and and
therefore have been you know left behind
out of the global economic global
economy so actually I can make it quick
I can answer the authentication question
the simple answer is yeah it's indeed
possible to do that the only slight
problem with that is that it raises
significant issues of privacy and a
whole lot of policy oriented issues or
technically it's not difficult or
impossible to authenticate but in terms
of deploying the authentication
mechanism using biometrics for example
there's a whole lot of privacy issues
that open up that I think we as a
society have not given much thought to
or much as much serious thought to right
so that's a quick answer to your
question and I just want to make one
point the last question here and then
I'll shut up I think the way to think
about leverage is not to say oh I'm a
poor country I don't have leverage I
think think about it is a wave of
economic expansion that is happening and
it is being attracted by forces of
economics which is basically inexpensive
and highly qualified labor to do the
same job that is being done at a more
expensive place right now and my
instinct or feeling is that education is
that force of attraction so if the
country is able to create a highly
educated workforce or a reasonably
educated workforce over time you will
create the basis to attract that wave of
economic expansion to your country and
that's 11 stuff from the question that's
on the personal interaction you know we
certainly see that is fundamental to the
human interaction and what drives
relationships and relationships are
really at the core of continuing to
build a successful market and being
innovative in forging new relationships
and you also need that interaction with
principals and with academia and with
your teachers in order to push you
forward and let you know that you can do
these things so although technology is
something that can certainly take us to
the next level and it does go beyond
different barriers of gender and raised
and language it does not replace
somebody that's there and helping you
have passed the barriers and helping you
to understand the things that you did
right and learn from the things that you
did wrong and teach you that because
there's nothing worse than
going to a room and having a
presentation whether it's with
accountants or others that don't have
that human interaction because that
trust and that loyalty is fundamental to
that relationship and we're seeing that
as a higher driver than necessarily how
you perform not it so that's critical to
continue and add to that question it's a
very complex one about how how one
addresses and maintains the human
dimension that cultivating an education
that really sensitizes one to
consciousness of self and other and to
to really think about that
cross-cultural awareness in addition to
the things you mentioned makes for at
least a promising way to forge those two
things to last point my side to your
question it will never replace human
interaction but for communities who have
nothing like Africa for instance it's
it's a first step towards the rest
identification I agree with predict
technologically speaking it very easy
but look again Dominican countries that
don't have IDs we don't have IDs no
photo IDs another piece of ID so yes you
can start with no freaking printing and
stuff like that but indeed it was issued
but that can be done that is done as
existing to their cell phones you know a
little some identification device so
that's one of the ways to do that in
Kenya they already do and banking using
mobile phones so they do many
transactions so satisfying students is
also possible did such a great job well
thank you very much I'm really sorry we
went so far beyond where when we're
supposed to stop but we did actually get
the students to participate so I'm very
happy about that thank you very much I
like to thank fans
you